this week scotland goes to the polls
in an election that could have profound
consequences for the whole of the united
kingdom
for the result will decide not just who
runs scotland
but whether the prospect of a second
independence referendum
will return to the forefront of our
national politics once more
and the leaders of scotland's three
biggest parties
know this moment matters a vote for the
snp in this
election is a vote for independence
isn't it i vote for the snp in this
election is firstly a vote for
experienced leadership to get us through
covert and yes then
after the pandemic it's a vote to give
people the choice
of independence an enticement for
nationalists
for unionists danger we know the threat
of holding another independence
referendum
if the snp win a majority now scottish
conservatives stop them getting that
majority
in 2016. five years ago at that election
we more than doubled the number of they
did win a majority it's a game changer
then isn't it
scottish labour too understand what's at
stake in this election
you're asking me about the game changing
i'm telling you what a game changer is
but i'm asking a very basic question
which is
if nicola stagion campaigns on having a
second referendum and they win a
majority she's got a mandate to do it
look it's her job to argue her own
mandate my job is to argue for what i
believe
i don't believe independence or a
referendum is the right thing for
scotland coming through this pandemic
do you accept the principle that it is
for the people of
scotland to decide that
look of course i accept the principle
that it's for the people of scotland to
decide their future and that's why
they're voting in this election campaign
but when it comes to independence
conservatives say the decisions
already been made do you accept the
principle
that it's right for the scottish people
to decide that
well the scottish people did decide that
of course back in 2014
we were told then by nicholas sturgeon
and the snp that referendum was the gold
standard of referendums
they were abide by the result of the
people of scotland more than 2 million
scots 55 said they wanted to remain part
of the united kingdom
more than 1.6 million wanted to remain
in the eu
too now i think most polls would tell us
the majority
position in scotland and of course the
other point here is that things
change pretty dramatically after 2014
the brexit referendum
whereby scotland has been taken out of
the eu against our will
really changed fundamentally the nature
of the
uk the conservatives were the difficult
position to defend
more than a million people in scotland
did vote to leave the european union and
when we voted in 2016 we knew it was
part of a uk
2 of scottish people wanted to remain
in the european union do you not think
that nicola sturgeon and the s
p have an argument to say that scottish
people
are not being represented we knew in
2016 the votes taken in scotland england
wales and northern ireland would be
combined together for a uk result
whether to leave
or stay in the eu brexit has given a
second independence referendum impetus
while an snp majority doesn't guarantee
independence
it does guarantee a fight if we win the
elections then we will bring forward the
legislation
and if boris johnson wants to challenge
that
legally which is what he would have to
do then we will rigorously and
vigorously defend the position
against that challenge no prime minister
is
immune to democracy even boris johnson
if it does happen
how does the prime minister of the
united kingdom
try and stop as second reflectors do you
just say that we're not doing it
well you're going to be really hard well
i don't think you would
expect me to to concede an election
before the votes have been
cast before they've been counted and
before we've seen an opportunity again
as we did in 2016
for the scottish conservatives to stop
that snp majority
we can focus on the other issues you're
not going to be able to stop it
people said that back in 2016. so to
avoid a referendum
unionists must stop an snp majority
polling suggests that's near impossible
isn't it wishful thinking uh to think
that nicola sturgeon is not going to win
a majority
not at all i don't think anything is
inevitable in this contest i know other
politicians might want to think it's
inevitable
and i'm not being as arrogant as that to
suggest that if something's inevitable
but nicholas sturgeon is focused on
another outcome
i'm fighting an election campaign to win
respectfully and i take nothing for
granted there's not an
ounce of complacency on my part but the
polls suggest that the snp right now is
on track
to win after the 2014 independence
referendum
both unionists and nationalists agreed
that the mata had been settled
for a generation but then came brexit
and the decision to take the uk out of
the eu
against the wishes of 62 of scots
turbocharged the issue once again
and no matter what unionist might say
about now not being the time
if nicola sturgeon wins an outright
majority
in the elections this week she will be
able to claim a democratic mandate for
that
second independence referendum it would
be
a disastrous setback for unionists and
it would
pose the most profound problem too
for boris johnson's premiership how to
prevent the breakup of a 300 year old
union
on his watch this then an election
as important in westminster as it is in
glasgow
the future of the union is set to
dominate
and unsettle our politics for years to
come
beth rigby sky news
and on your screen now you can see the
list of parties and their leaders
or league candidates standing across
scotland at the elections
this thursday more details about your
constituency and the candidates standing
can also be found on your local council
webpage